Coast to Coast with stories that matter
most
watching local news with nine-time Emmy
Award winner Chet van Jansen and now
here's Chad
thanks yeah
you didn't know that about me did you
well now you do and stop laughing all
right it's local news it's a segment
where each guest has to share a real
news story from wherever they're from
and then I vote on the winner and that
person gets a swimming lesson from Hans
my pool boy
I better win
control yourself Chris all right uh Joe
why don't you go first with your where
are you from Joe Greg I'm from State
College Pennsylvania home of Penn State
University go
pit
well done excellent I've been to State
College it's beautiful there beautiful
Town beautiful Town yeah yeah yeah
what's the news tell us what's happening
there what's percolating well an
industry group Greg is doing a March
Madness style bracket of the top things
made in the state of Pennsylvania
they're down to the final eight and uh
all we have left that aren't food are
Zippos the lighters and Martin guitars
very high-end acoustic guitar
manufacturers and that made me think
we're in big trouble you know because uh
if we go to war with with China even if
we win the war there's not going to be
any like antibiotics or corsets
yeah
we need to make stuff Craig oh I see
what you mean we need to start making
stuff listen this this swimming lesson
is key for your fight with Ronda Rousey
you need to come back to him yeah
of course sets are important I guess
yeah and we've got some great products
we've got Yingling lager that's yeah
that's Pottsville Pennsylvania but it's
it's all food it's Primanti Brothers
It's pierogies you need to we need
kisses we need more industry is what
you're saying yeah we're just getting
fat all right which uh
Joe you look great thank you Chris help
you keep her under yeah
Chris what are you you're rubbing your
hands I'm rubbing my hands all right
tell me what I'm from Winchester
Virginia this on the Virginia West
Virginia border uh and we have some
really great stories that are going on
right now one of the best though is an
attempted robbery of the Ramada Inn in
Shenandoah County
get this these are very very smart women
who attempted this robbery three women
show up in a car together two of them
get out and try to break into the Ramada
in office to steal money I assume right
and they can't get in the door so they
go back and they get in the car The
Third Woman then gets out of the car and
pretends to be an Amazon delivery guy
and said I'm not one of the robbers I'm
an Amazon delivery guy that doesn't work
they call the police what I left out in
these details is that all three of them
were wearing ski masks
one of them said she just happened to be
there she had nothing to do with it well
why the hell were you wearing a ski mask
she said it was very windy that day
that's pretty good that's pretty good
it's awesome I love where I'm from yeah
you are you're from a beautiful
beautiful part of the country can I see
that milk shot again that woman on the
right there she looks very very sad and
I'd say I think if I'm gonna do a mug
shot I'm at least gonna smile because if
I could just bring joy to somebody's
life you know even in my mug shot just
like this is you know what I'm gonna do
this right now cat she should smile more
don't you lie don't you women love it
when they're told they have to smile
more she should you know she smiled more
she probably wouldn't be in jail
guess what if I if I get arrested for
trying to break into the Ramada Inn and
I'm wearing a ski you're gonna smile Pro
scene is an Amazon delivery guy I ain't
smiling either all right Tyrus
uh which one am I from because I'm from
everywhere and nowhere but uh for this
is Boston I believe uh
someone who's Wicked stupid decided to
sue Dunkin Donuts because the app is too
expensive
too lazy you can't drive and go to the
drive-through and get your Donuts or
even worse get out of the car walk in
and get them like this is absolutely
ridiculous he's doing because he says
the app's too expensive yeah
how much is the app isn't it like a dog
if you are downloading an app for donuts
seriously
taste dismissed sorry
I'm sorry like that argument not having
it that's up there with CNN and raises
me
I love Dunkin Donuts I love Dunkin
Donuts everyone loves Dunkin Donuts okay
it's the place you go when Krispy Kremes
is closed but has anyone ever I'm
kidding has anyone ever do you have a do
you need a donut app no no I just go
once you know and you're the you have
apps you have food and stuff yeah a lot
of anyone here have a donut app maybe
it's you want to just get the line
sometimes Tyrus
[Laughter]
and then he just walks by the line and
they hand him this thing and you feel
really good you do this you've done that
at the airport haven't you uh well no I
uh I have Premier access so I have to
wait in line with the unwashed masses
[Music]
gotta get that clear man yeah yeah clear
yeah all right cat
Michigan mine's really sad oh geez
you're here to sadly report the closing
of 26 Burger Kings throughout the state
of Michigan I know Burger King was a
huge part of my childhood yeah yeah why
are they closing them is it just lack
you know what it is they can't find
enough people I'm too emotionally
distraught to have looked into it that
much
it was no every Memorial Day Weekend the
Sunday of every Memorial Day weekend we
would drive to Cary Ohio to go to the
shrain shrine of Our Lady of consolation
and then we'd go to church and then
afterwards we got to go to the religious
store and then go to the basement and
then look at all the saints bones
um you guys just do secular stuff for
Memorial Day
like the beach not me uh and then we got
to eat meatloaf sandwiches and then we
had to go back to church well actually
we walked in A procession around the
block praying the rosary but then on the
way home we got to go to Burger King and
I got to get whatever I wanted
you earned it yeah
yeah it was a lot of religious stuff on
other days too
you know what's sad is that people used
to go to like Burger King and McDonald's
and sit in the restaurant and it was a
fun family thing
now unless you're looking for some crack
or a fist fight just don't go yeah
you're right it's like when I was
growing up in the 70s that was if you
got a good grade you went to McDonald's
yeah yeah Friday it was always Fridays
go down you did like sitting around
there it would be so exciting even with
the small order of fries that's they
only had one size when I was young
well that was good for you with your
little hands you know
they turned against me
I'm making fun of my tiny hands
they really are delicate and precious
they're so cute they're like a baby's
hands
sometimes I'll wake up and they're on my
face
we're gonna stop there all right yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else